[Applause]
[Music]
Uruguay is a country famous for soccer
as we celebrate Russia's World Cup this
summer we've checked the Hall of Fame
and there are only eight countries that
have ever won a final Uruguay a really
small country with a little more than 3
million inhabitants while there one of
them they've even won the Cup twice and
in both cases they beat their neighbors
Brazil and Argentina
so in today's video we're going to talk
about how Uruguay has beaten their
neighbors but not in soccer but rather
in economics yes alongside Chile Uruguay
is the wealthiest country in America
when it comes to GDP per capita but it's
also one of the most stable when it
comes to politics and it has some of the
best public services but there's even
more to this story we can actually say
that Uruguay is the model for the entire
South American left-wing have you ever
heard about their former president Jose
Mujica he's known as the world's poorest
president and he quickly became the
ultimate left-wing rock star he's the
only world leader who refused to live in
the presidential palace and kept driving
an old Volkswagen instead of an
expensive official car
[Music]
from a life philosophy perspective I
believe it's better to live with little
luggage just the minimum necessary no
material complexity if you have too much
complexity you end up spending too much
time nevertheless while no he can't have
this simple lifestyle his country grew
economically it attracted foreign
companies and it became the pioneer with
social rights with mihika as president
Uruguay passed a bill for the
legalization of same-sex marriage but
undoubtedly
his most famous policy was the
legalization of recreational marijuana
sales way before California or any other
country Uruguay was the first country to
legalize the sale and consumption of
wheat and the country's progress it
doesn't stop there if you take a static
picture of Uruguay you will see a
country that arguably is the best place
to live in all the South America
if you take a static picture of Uruguay
you will see a country that arguably is
the best place to live in all of South
America unlike Brazil and Argentina
Uruguay is economy hasn't stopped
growing since 2002 ever thriving middle
class since the highest wages in the
region along with Chile but hold on a
minute because not everything is a field
Rosa's here in fact as such a prosperous
country you might expect it to have
plenty of immigrants right well the
reality is actually really different and
this is not because they have strong
immigration laws people just don't pick
Uruguay as a country of residence
because well things are actually
starting to go rather sour they have
around an 8 percent unemployment rate
and their economic growth speed is
reducing well other countries like Peru
and Chile seem to offer opportunities
for everyone so today's question is why
has Uruguay economy worked out so well
until now and what are the current
problems they're facing well today we're
going to answer all of those questions
but before we do let's take a look back
at the history Americas which Erland
Uruguay was born in 1830 after a war
between Brazil and Argentina the British
worked to negotiate the peace agreements
and they badly wanted Uruguay to be an
independent country
[Music]
so why was this well Montevideo's
harbour was a jewel and they didn't want
it ending up in Brazilian or Argentinean
hands back then Uruguay
it was almost uninhabited it was
inhabited by a tribe called the Charo US
but they were soon exterminated this is
why unlike many other South American
countries most of uruguay UNS have a
european ethnicity mainly spanish and
italian roots in those times if you were
an ambitious boy looking for a career
and an opportunity to make money uruguay
was the place to go it was better than
America and it was better than Australia
it was a modern democracy with rule of
law and a thriving economy until the 60s
of the 20th century this country was
among the wealthiest in the world
it was way richer than many European
nations in fact so now you might be
wondering well what exactly happens
because despite being prosperous among
South American nations Uruguay is still
way behind any European country let
alone America so what happens to make
them stop growing so dramatically well
the answer lies in of all things the
European Union yeah you heard me right
Divya if you thought this idea of a
trade war was Donald Trump's invention
and they were very mistaken in the year
1958 the European single market was
created and one of the first things they
did was to protect their agriculture
from Uruguayan meat
this meant that guru quite lost their
biggest customer the United States
didn't want to trade with them either it
was in the middle of the Cold War and
they were too busy dealing with bigger
problems than this little country to pay
attention so day by day Uruguay became
stagnant and the government's in mont of
a day over country's capital they didn't
have any other alternative than to look
to their neighbors Argentina
all of a sudden Uruguayan Argentina
became something like the Robert
Rodriguez and Quentin Tarantino of South
America
well if Argentina had a financial crisis
so did Uruguay if Argentina had a
military dictatorship well so did
Uruguay if Argentina had a democracy
well yes so did Uruguay so dear viewer
well what happens in Argentina in the
year 2002 well they had the biggest
financial crisis in all of history the
now-infamous
core alito and in the very same year
Uruguay is GDP fell by seven point seven
percent which was a big time catastrophe
and this was when Uruguay realized they
had to find new trade partners but how
would they do that
well let's look into it zero kilometer
of South America during the 1980s
Uruguay returned to democracy and the
government did something really really
interesting they created the so called
zonas Franco's these were special
territories inside of the country where
companies were free to not pay taxes no
v80 no income tax no corporate tax the
only request was that 75% of the jobs be
given to locals maybe this reminds you
of something because it's pretty much
the same idea as the special economic
zones that exist in China that we like
so much here at visual politics today
Uruguay has 11 tax-free zones
[Music]
there are three different kinds first we
have those oriented to logistics at
international trade after that we have
the zones that are designed for
attracting multinational corporations
that can use them as the headquarters
for the South American operation finally
we have the areas that are meant to have
high-tech industry this is why Uruguay
is a regional leader in things such as
pharmaceutical research and software but
this is not the end of the story here
these tax free zones have a unique
advantage something that makes Uruguay
and model for other countries yes if you
are here we're talking about political
stability in the Year 2005 year ago I
changed its government leadership and
they had at last
left-wing presidents there would be to
bear vasquez from the open front party
you see in most South American countries
having such an ideological shift in the
government means that most of the work
made by the previous administrations
simply goes into the trash
[Music]
so you might think that under a
brand-new left-wing government those tax
reasons would no longer exist right well
the reality it actually couldn't be more
different and this is the great thing
about this country
the bipartisan consensus this is why
between 2005 and 2014 the accumulated
investment in these tax-free zones rose
to almost six billion dollars and all of
this happens while first Vasquez and
then Jose Mujica managed the country but
again in one little corner here
see look at those who are not looking
only for profit they also want safe and
this is what Virg Y has to offer it's
not a matter of this or the other
government this is a genuine org y an
attitude neck beautiful where you and I
you might wonder well what does Uruguay
get from these tax free zones well give
you a there is a double benefit to them
actually on the one hands they are able
to appeal to industries that otherwise
would have set up in other countries
with bigger markets and these foreign
companies need providers this is why
sooner than expected many small
enterprises are created around the
country and of course they require
highly skilled labor and that means good
salaries this is why Uruguay ins don't
need to emigrate in order to find a good
job
[Music]
but hold on a moment here because we
said that Uruguay needs to change their
trade partners right maybe you remember
how we said that they could no longer
depends on Argentina or Brazil for their
exports so you might now be wondering
well what are the tax-free zones have to
do with all of this well just think
about it thanks to these innovative
industries that set up in the country
Uruguay could stop relying on the
commodity sector prior to this their
economy was based mainly on science on
meat today they create products that
have more value-added it's only give you
an example all of the syrup needed in
Pepsi drinks sold across all of South
America is created in Uruguay in fact
it's a popular type of Pepsi in Japan
called Pepsi uzuki this is made with a
plant called sweet theme and again the
syrup for this beverage is produced 200
kilometers away from Montevideo in total
Pepsi represents 7% of everything the
country exports and this is not the only
example one of the biggest paper making
companies on the planet a Finnish
company called UPM has one of their main
factories in Uruguay and they've already
announced the construction of a brand
new facility that might represent a
whole 2.5 percent extra GDP for the
country and if that isn't enough Uruguay
is also a software leader
[Music]
eight were required software developers
among the best in all of Latin America
in summary 30% of Uruguay's exports are
produced from these tax-free zones and
yes who's the main buyer here well let
me give you a clue it starts with a C
and H and I and it ends in Na nowadays
Brazil and Argentina receive just 20% of
this country's exports another good
friend of Uruguay is in Netherlands the
Rotterdam Harbor is the gateway to
Europe and many of the Uruguayan exports
go that way to make a comparison Chile's
economy despite being the wealthiest in
the region is heavily reliant on that
copper mining half of their exports of
this commodity alone Uruguay instead
it's got a diversified economy we've
talked about software paper drinks and
of course soy and meat but if you
thought everything is all sunshine and
rainbows and hold on a second because
things are not quite as perfect as you
might think
[Music]
[Applause]
party vs. government as we said before
since the Year 2005 Uruguay has had a
left-wing government more specifically
this country has been managed by the
open fronts party and one thing is
certainly true they are worthy of that
name because it is really an open party
with plenty of different ideologies
inside this is why despite what it looks
like arguments a pretty common thing in
the party so on the one hand despite the
different presidents Uruguay has had the
same Finance Minister for the last 13
years his name is Denny Lewis story and
you could say that he's one of the
architects of this Uruguayan stability
but on the other hands the open front is
really a battlefront between the radical
wing and the moderate wing champions by
to bear Vasquez Jose maker the left-wing
rock star he's somewhere in the middle
and this is why anytime Uruguayan
government wants to sign a free trade
deal with any other country they must
face their own party opposition it
happens during the first vasquez
administration when they tried to sign a
deal with the United States it happens
when they tried to sign a deal with
Chile and it might now happen as they
want to sign a deal with China in Olano
million today 2018 we will mark 30 years
of diplomatic relations with China and
this is why we have put this date as a
deadline to sign a free trade deal in
this case Uruguayan companies would save
more than a hundred million dollars in
needless tariffs but this radical wing
of the open front seems to be allergic
to the word free trade and if this was
not enough some critics claimed that
Daniel ER a story the Finance Minister
spends too little
but this is actually one of the biggest
problems in ER why after Venezuela and
Argentina Uruguay has the largest share
of civil servants in the region one out
of five workers is employed by the
government and if you add to this the
enormous presence of an illegal economy
you'll understand why just one-third of
Uruguayan adults work for private
companies in most developed nations this
number is more than half
[Music]
of course compared with Argentina or
Brazil Uruguay is a paradise on earth
but the truth is if they want to keep
growing they must solve these problems
as soon as possible
[Music]
so now the final question is do you
think Uruguay should sign those free
trade deals do you think it is still
worth investing in as a country well
please leave your answer in the comment
section below and as always please visit
our friends at reconsider Mediacom
that's the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that we're not
mine
also don't forget to support us on
patreon where you can get access to
exclusive content and if you like this
video please do give us a thumbs up and
as always I'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and here even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast see you there
[Music]